thanks Yasser I'm with vodimir furka but
this is the chief of staff for the Prime
Minister here in Croatia zvonimir first
of all welcome to the show tell us about
your first move uh how excited were you
to do that I'm always excited
since we have the branches too for the
fourth time in Croatia it's a really a
very big event and it's it's incredible
to have so many
top uh the word just player Magnus
Carson of course Wishy and then the the
former
world champion of course Gary kasperov
who is our fellow Citizen and who help
us a lot to bring branches to the
creation we were grateful for that and
that's the reason why also the the
government is supporting it and the
Prime Minister also
came for my I don't know I think the
third time to open uh officially the
grandchester this year also so it's uh
it's really a very nice for the for the
Young Generation especially to have such
a number of top players to see from
first hand their incredible moves and
it's very important for us also to
develop chess in schools tell us about
that what are the goals the long-term
goals for the Young Generation
actually you you are aware that we are
the only country uh in the world with
the chess board on our flag so it's uh
the grandchester had to be in in Croatia
at least to that Croatia had to be among
the countries hosting grantchester and
uh of course I'm kidding but uh
historically the very first creation
chessboard was eight by eight now it's
five by five so we really had a true
chess board on our on our
coat of arms and for us it's very
important to develop a chess especially
in school because
you have so many games so many video
games but none of them can compete with
the with chess when it comes to how long
we play chess for one Millennium and uh
one 15th centuries and
I'm sure that the chess will be played
for many many centuries to come and and
from that perspective it will be told
you know all the video games so it's uh
it's uh something which is
um uh very
let's say a part of of the general
culture in Croatia and it's it develops
also many skills we very useful for what
would you say those main attributes that
just developed I I will say fair play I
will say also the the ability to
of self-control controlling motion
because you see a good move but you
don't want it to be seen by your
opponent you don't have to you you have
to you know show no emotion but also you
have to uh you
you
have to decide not
between two incredible good moves but
most of the time among the less worse
move so it's a it's a school of deciding
how to decide what is you know the the
best trade-off and and also combining
calculating
logic analysis ethics and also maybe a
very good balance between strategy and
tactics because for instance the goal is
maybe 90 strategy while I would say
maybe I'm wrong but that chess is half
half so it's a very good in my view a
very good game Sorry mirror I'm going to
put you on the spot right now who is
your favorite player in this
of course we have our fellow cities and
Evan sharich who was the European
Champions and we are supporting even of
course and
for the other players it's it's really
difficult to to choose a among among
among them because they have a very
different style of playing and there is
a also a very big difference in
generation we have a vision and who is a
veteran and he's really amazing yeah
yeah and we have a Young Generation like
vocash like firoza and and some others
and so it's I think it will be
interesting interesting and and of
course Magnus Carson who is always a
very uh
a combination he
he does and Fabiano here also we just uh
Fabiano is also incredible and
so
we hope that even charity will do its
best so when we were listening to you
and seeing your knowledge of Chess I
think Croatian chess is definitely on
good hands thank you very much for thank
you very much for inviting me
thank you Christian it's always nice
when